North Korean leader Kim jong-un has
arrived in the city of Vladivostok and
Russia's Far East ahead of his
first-ever summit with Lauda Mir Putin
the meeting will take place on Thursday
he was greeted by authorities and a
military parade in his honor our
correspondent in Leo petrenko was there
soon after this train crossed the North
Korea Russia border the Supreme Leader
said that he was happy to be in this
country and that he wants this trip to
be successful and fruitful I come to
Russia with the warmth of our people and
I hope my visit will be successful and
productive I also hope that during our
negotiations with honourable President
Putin I'll be able to discuss the
matters of resolving the problems on the
Korean Peninsula as well as our
bilateral relations what exactly he
means by that we can only guess all this
is the so so to say the entourage of Kim
Jong Un's arrival in Vladivostok
[Music]
[Applause]
literally minutes after the North Korean
supreme leader got inside his limo we
were given the opportunity to come
closer to his armored train
[Music]
so unfortunately I won't be able to show
you or see for myself any of the
extraordinary facilities inside that
train that was used by Kim Jong Un's
father I was trying to look through the
window but obviously no chances and the
security guards are watching carefully
to make sure that we don't touch it I've
already been told off by them inside it
there are high tech communication
facilities
several conference room as well as
luxury living quarters in the middle of
the train there's a special room for Kim
Jong whose wife and right next to it two
separate parts for bodyguards there are
two restaurants one is for the supreme
leader himself and the second one is for
the entire delegation there's even a
special section for the leaders limo in
there the one that we saw on the station
square and that massive armored vehicle
can actually fit into one of those now
in terms of the political context of
this mean thing we have to remember what
happened a few months ago and also last
year to face-to-face meetings with an
American president Donald Trump the
world expected to break through but it
didn't happen
no agreements or deals were signed
pingyang expected some positive steps
from Washington to be made in response
to the concessions from the DPRK one of
the things they said they did was
destroying a number of nuclear
facilities that they used to have what
they got instead was more pressure and
threats of new sanctions and what we
found out eventually was that Kim Jong
hoon was heading to Russia and the next
leader he's gonna meet is Vladimir Putin
not Donald Trump so definitely we are
expecting them to discuss the
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
of course Moscow's role and where it
stands in this conflict is completely
different to that of Washington but if
once the chem Putin summit is over we
hear about some breakthrough decisions
being made in Pyongyang that is really
going to be a diplomatic game changer
the Chairman will of the DPRK will spend
the night at a hotel located on Russky
Island the North Korean delegation
requested a range of traditional Russian
dishes to be served during the stay so
on the menu is borscht a soup made from
beets
L mean II which is meat baked in dough
and of course caviar
well the main event of the summit will
be on Thursday Kim Jong had plenty to
occupy him now us set to visit major
factories as well as the headquarters of
the Russian naval fleet political
analyst Chris Bambury outlined his
expectations for Thursday's meeting I
think Putin is going to say take it easy
here you need to go his advice would be
you need to take it graduate and make
sure any step you take is as a
reciprocal step from the Americans so I
think they'll be discussing the nuclear
deal and how the North Koreans can play
their card and I think Kim Jong will
want Putin's advice advice here and I
think Putin will retained in to say a
bit more hardball please play hardball
with the Americans a bit a bit more so
again I'm not thinking anything really
you know dramatic here but I think it
American Russia or make it clear that
well it doesn't side with North Korea in
terms of developing nuclear missiles it
understands why North Korea wants this
nuclear program and understands why you
know what the Americans have to treat
the North Koreans with respect in these
negotiations if the negotiations resume
so Vladimir Putin will meet Kim jong-un
tomorrow and of course will be across
events for you so do stay with RT for
the latest
[Music]
you